♪ (disco) ♪
- En 1978, où qu'on se trouve
résonnaient les chansons de
la comédie musicale à succès
"Grease".
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est le premier film qu'a vu
Geneviève Borne au cinéma.
Geneviève, toi, tu n'aimes pas
"Grease"... tu adores!
GENEVIÈVE BORNE, animatrice
- J'adore "Grease", c'est le
film que j'ai vu le plus souvent
dans ma vie, je pourrais
le regarder encore
cette semaine, je le regarde
tout le temps, c'est un film
qui me rend joyeuse.
♪ Summer loving had me a blast ♪
♪ Summer loving
happened so fast ♪
- "Grease", ce sont des chansons
qui nous restent en tête,
des chorégraphies 1000 fois
immitées et une belle histoire
d'amour entre la douce Sandy
Olsen, interprétée par Olivia
Newton-John, et le rebel Danny
Zucco, incarné par un John
Travolta au sommet de sa gloire
après le succès de
"Saturday Night Fever".
♪ I got chills
they're multiplying ♪
- C'est vraiment la naissance
d'un couple mythique,
c'est vraiment un des couples
les plus marquants de l'histoire
du cinéma et de la musique :
leur façon de danser, leur façon
de chanter ensemble, leurs voix
ensemble sont tellement belles!
Ils sont beaux à l'écran
et on y croit. On y croit,
à leur histoire d'amour,
complètement!
♪ Nothin' left for me to do ♪
♪ You're the one that I want ♪
♪ You are the one I want ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, honey ♪
- Après avoir été un succès
sur Broadway au début des années
70, la comédie musicale
est adaptée pour le cinéma
à Hollywood. Pour l'occasion,
quatre nouvelles chansons, dont
la pièce "Grease", sont ajoutées
à la trame sonore du film pour
s'assurer des passages radio.
♪ ♪ ♪
MIKE GAUTHIER, animateur
et chroniqueur musical
- T'sais, quand t'as une grande
chanson qui est associée à
un film, ça amène du monde dans
les salles de cinéma parce que
c'est de la pub gratuite que
tu as, alors "Grease", c'était
des succès qui se collaient
et en plus, la gang qui a fait
"Grease", c'était la même gang
qui avait fait "Saturday Night
Fever". Je pense qu'ils
connaissaient la formule un peu!
♪ ♪ ♪
- La chanson "Grease" a été
composée Barry Gibb des Bee Gees
et interprétée par Frankie
Valli, qui avait connu le succès
avec le groupe The Four Seasons.
- La chanson "Grease",
elle jouait à l'endroit où
je faisais du patin à roulettes,
elle jouait dans les
discothèques, elle jouait
à la radio tout le temps,
partout, partout!
♪ ♪ ♪
- La recette du succès
de "Grease" : des vedettes,
des chorégraphies, des tubes
et de la nostalgie, car l'action
se déroule dans les années 50.
- Il y a toujours comme
des générations qui s'accrochent
aux générations précédentes,
ça fait que là, il y avait
le côté brillantine,
le "Brylcreem", tout ça, qu'on
retrouve là-dedans. Ça fait que
c'est pour ça que ça a obtenu
un si grand succès.
- Les paroles parlent beaucoup
de cet espoir qui habite
les jeunes quand ils terminent
le secondaire, t'sais, de mettre
de côté les conventions et
de croire en nous, de croire que
tout est possible, qu'on peut
atteindre nos rêves.
C'est vraiment ça, "Grease",
alors c'est vraiment
une chanson d'espoir.
♪ Summer dreams ♪
- Le service de streaming
Paramount+ a récemment annoncé
avoir commandé "Grease : Rise of
the Pink Ladies", un antépisode
de la comédie musicale culte
de 1978, dont la date de sortie
n'est pas encore connue.
Restera à voir si les hits
seront aussi nombreux et si la
nostalgie fait toujours recette.
♪ We go together ♪
♪ Like rama lama lama
ka dinga da dinga dong ♪
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.